bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end l
émission consacrée à vos loisirs et vos
idées de sorties alors numéro un peu
spécial c'est le dernier de la saison
nous allons vous de vous donner le
maximum d'idées loisirs pour vos
vacances d'été
on commence tout de suite avec une autre
première invitée elle et on part du côté
de lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines coup de projecteur sur les
activités qui se dérouleront tout au
long de l'été avec notre invité
guillaume durand bonjour bonjour vous
êtes responsable adjoint du service
événementiel de ses titres de cette île
de loisirs alors par où commencer
est ce que il ya des nouveautés c'était
vrai oui cet été il ya des nouveautés ça
bouge beaucoup sur la ligne de loisirs
donc pour les nouveautés on s'est doté
d'une structure de ventriglisse
notamment les ventes et lis donc c'est
une structure gonflable avec trois voix
sur 20 mètres qui permet de glisser
dessus notamment sur le ventre voilà qui
s'intègre dans un nouveau projet qui a
mis en place en compensation de la
fermeture exceptionnelle de la piscine à
vagues pour de grosses rénovations de
gros travaux et donc on a créé un
village loisirs à destination des
centres de loisirs et cette activité
vient s'intégrer dans ce village loisirs
entre la beauté éventuellement également
donc des nouveaux ateliers au niveau du
parcours branché loisirs notamment avec
un atelier de vélo sur un fils comme un
funambule également des nouveaux paddle
on vient de se doter de quatre paddle
donc collectif on peut monter jusqu'à 8
personnes dessus au niveau du centre de
voile à qui sont destinés ces nouvelles
activités un public particulier alors il
ya différentes activités en fonction du
public c'est vrai que sur ligne de
loisirs on accueille autant les
particuliers donc les familles également
les groupes type centre de loisirs
scolaire est également les entreprises
donc au niveau des groupes notamment cet
été il ya deux gros projets le village
loisirs le village de thé sportif alors
qu'est ce que le village loisirs va
commencer par là alors dans un premier
temps le village loisirs et donc comme
son nom l'indiqué un village constitué
de plusieurs activités se déroule du 6
au 24 juillet au niveau de l'espace
événementiel de la piscine à vagues et
pour ce faire
donc les trois principales activités
sont du vent très lisse de la cua volet
c'est à dire donc on s'est doté d'une
petite piscine hors sol où on peut
pratiquer justement du volet dans l'eau
est également des sports de plage beach
volley ce handball flag rugby également
oui toutes ces activités sont
disponibles le village d'été sportif à
présent alors le village d'été sportif
succèdent justement au village loisirs
c'est un projet qui est soutenu par le
conseil régional est également nous
mettons en place ce projet à destination
des centres de loisirs pour les jeunes
de 11 à 17 ans donc c'est une action
complètement gratuite et libre d'accès
bien sûr sur inscription pour réserver
les différents créneaux et dans les
nouveautés au niveau des activités
sportives bon point également pratique
et donc de la boxe du hockey sur gazon
du bmx
en plus des activités de l'édition
précédente tel que la zumba
l'initiation aux gestes qui sauvent
également
c'est déjà pas mal ce sera donc du 27
juillet au 28 août
c'est un portif on continue peut-être
avec des activités qu'on peut faire en
famille il a pas mal oui il y en a
beaucoup bien sûr l'ensemble des
activités de ligne de loisirs tels que
le parcours branché loisirs au niveau du
centre de voile avec les activités de
location de canoë ou de catamarans
également balades à cheval mais
également une des nouveautés qui
fonctionne plutôt bien cette année c'est
le balad énigmes qui est un parcours
donc de trois kilomètres à faire sur
l'hymne de loisirs et pour ce faire on
doit répondre à des énigmes réaliser des
petits défis tout autour de deux lignes
de loisirs ce qui permet de travailler
le cerveau et les gens dont le dimanche
19 juillet un événement bien précis
cette fois ci le judo tour oui on
accueille le judo tour donc c'est le
comité départemental de judo qui vient
sur la ligne de loisirs avec ses
animateurs et be2 judo pour initier le
tout public
les plus jeunes comme les plus grands à
partir de 6 ans à cette activité de judo
c'est une activité qui sera également un
libre d'accès gratuite au niveau de la
raquette événementiel très bien et il y
aura également des rencontres avec des
athlètes membres de l'équipe de france
oui également sont présents des membres
de l'équipe de france sur ce parvis pour
les grands fans
un événement canoë nature le 29 août
également oui on organise également cet
événement
donc c'est en rapport avec la réserve
naturelle ou sur réservation on pourra
s'inscrire à ce créneau qui permettra de
découvrir la réserve naturelle sur l'eau
et depuis l'eau en canoë oui tous les
vendredis en fait il ya des ateliers à
destination des groupes sur la période
de juillet-août également du lundi au
vendredi pour le tout public on peut
venir s'initier à l'entretien des
animaux à pouvoir les brosser les
peigner toute l'année et qui continue
cet été ses serments il est également
possible de passer une nuit dans une
yourte ou tipi
oui on a des logements atypiques voilà
on peut accueillir jusqu'à 20 personnes
dans répartis dans des yourtes eur28 ou
de deux personnes avec une grande yourte
collective qui permet également de
pouvoir cuisiner puisqu'elle est
totalement aménagé on n'a pas parlé
la fermeture exceptionnelle de la
piscine à vagues nous expliquer un peu
ce qui va se passer
alors cette année 1 en raison
d'importants travaux de rénovation n'a
pas pu ouvrir le bassin est donc
la piscine à vagues pour cet été dans
l'objectif justement de l'ouvrir la
saison prochaine peut-être parler
rapidement des nouveaux accès au si oui
depuis depuis le 1er juin donc on a mis
en place des nouveaux actes les quatre
voies d'entrée et de voies de sortie
contre une saison passée prochainement
bien sûr les saint quentinois pourront
se doter d'une carte à puce qui va
remplacer la carte magnétique donc
directement auprès de l'accueil de l'île
de loisirs ne seront pas distribués dans
les mairies de la commune de saint
quentin en yvelines comme l'était
auparavant et également des nouveaux
moyens de paiement pour régner soit en
carte bleue ou en monnaie merci beaucoup
guillaume durand pour toutes ces
informations et puis un bel été à vous
merci à vous on poursuit avec la page
spectacle de cette édition la prochaine
saison de la ferme de bel ébat est déjà
prête son directeur ioan lavabre nous la
présente c'est la chronique de nicolas
gervais bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes
à nos fermes de belles et bars
exactement et nous allons rencontrer le
directeur ioan là-bas bon voilà c'est
maintenant c'est tout de suite c'est
parti
galeries photos des buildings c'est une
saison qui propose à nos spectateurs un
voyage un voyage autour du monde
en une quarantaine de spectacles a comme
ça et on va on va explorer alors à la
fois des spectacles donc un anglais
allemand l'italie l'espagne mais
également l'amérique latine la norvège
la biélorussie l'algérie le japon la
syrie le bangladesh
mina est une petite fille qui a souvent
du mal à s'endormir
un immense oiseau sort de l'oreiller
c'est la loose base à l'oiseau blanc de
madagascar qui emporte ni'lin sur ses
ailes inoni jeune aboubakar la
coloration de la ferme de bel ébat c'est
avant tout le théâtre même si on va on
va retrouver de la danse et des
spectacles musicaux c'est le théâtre
dans son acceptation large il ya
évidemment une une barbe elle qui est
fait à la marionnette le théâtre je
dirais dans un premier temps et le
théâtre contemporain avec une place très
importante accordée à la création sur 41
spectacle on en a 21 qui sont des
créations
ça va me pousser
déferré mais je n'en veux pas sort de
monte en première ligne
ni une des grandes nouveautés de cette
saison la ferme de bel ébat c'est que
nous allons accueillir quatre compagnies
pour des résidences longue on avait
l'habitude jusqu'à présent d'accueillir
les compagnies pour des créations sur
des temps assez court
deux ou trois semaines puis le spectacle
nous allons continuer cela mais parmi
les compagnies en résidence il y en aura
quatre qui resteront en résidence pour
trois ans alors il s'agit de la
compagnie ncca aude a dirigé par
godefroy ségal de la compagnie pas mais
vos lubies de la conteuse praline gay
para mais également le dock deux groupes
d'aurélie vingtaine dalle et la
compagnie viva anthony magnier
alors on danse on va avoir de la danse
pour le jeune public notamment spectacle
si ça se trouve les poissons sont très
drôles pour les tout-petits à partir
d'un an et demi et puis la forêt
ébouriffés un très joli spectacle des
frères ben haim sur l'univers du conte
fantastique
ce matin d'une forêt a poussé dans ma
tête
il me regarde tous les monstres contre
ce port
la double inconstance de marivaux qui
sera très attendu et un fil à la patte
de la compagnie viva en résidence voilà
la célèbre pièce de feydeau qui
normalement devrait faire un tabac
également les animals un diptyque sur
les textes d'eugène labiche mis en scène
par jean voit l'eau et nous aurons
également la création d'hôtels l'eau par
la compagnie viva othello de shakespeare
et la mort de danton de genre une bûche
nerfs
nous accueillerons la saison prochaine
une formidable compagnie de la
marionnette qui s'appelle les anges au
plafond avec deux spectacles alors une
création une création très mystérieuse
sur laquelle je ne peux pas vous dire
grand chose sinon que ça m'aidera magie
nouvelle et marionnettes ça s'appelle r
ah j'ai eu et nous accueillons cette
même compagnie avec les mains de camille
ou le temps de l'oubli un spectacle de
marionnettes et de musique qui évoque la
vie de camille claudel un spectacle
absolument magnifique teint d'intimité
une pureté égaré un mouvement comme un
enfant loin du monumental se sent chez
soi
si bien qu'en regardant franchement on
ne sait pas qui de l'oeuvre de nous et
de chair
c'est bouleversant
à
un cycle consacré à la musique sacrée un
site qui s'appelle sacrée musique et qui
est un voyage on va avoir à la fois de
la musique baroque de la musique
contemporaine
et puis de la musique de différentes
traditions tradition chrétienne
tradition juive avec un concert de
musique hassidique est également la
musique soufie avec away de bois saône à
l'auditorium de la batterie qui chante
les poètes soufis du viiie siècle
accompagné au luth c'est une voix
vraiment admirable
elle est un peu de cinéma avec une autre
rendez vous traditionnel le coup de
coeur de la semaine dans professionnels
du 7e art celui de bertrand pigné des
yeux d'elsa à saint-cyr-l'ecole au
cinéma les yeux d'elsa le coup de coeur
à partir du 2 ce mercredi 8 juillet
c'est non pas un mais deux coups de
coeur un coup de coeur plus pour les
grands un coup de coeur cannois un coup
dur qui s'appelle la loi du marché qui a
valu à vincent lindon le prix
d'interprétation à cannes en mai dernier
vincent lindon qui a été très émouvant
en recevant son prix les aussi
énormément dans ce film de stéphane
brizé un film qui a pour principe de
départ de n'avoir qu'un seul acteur
professionnel vincent lindon lui même
toutes les autres acteurs qui
l'entourent sont des personnes qui sont
des acteurs non professionnels ou des
personnes qui vivent dans leur situation
réelle les événements qui sont montrés
alors évidemment c'est un film un peu
difficile on connaît vos des hôtels si
je sauvegarde pour voir ces scans tous
les articles vu qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup
de départs en pré retraite
j'ai essayé de virer du personnel ça
nous raconte l'histoire d'un chômeur en
fin de droits d'une cinquantaine
d'années qui luttent pour faire vivre sa
famille et lui même ayant un enfant
handicapé mais vraiment un très grand
film de cinéma une très belle une très
belle histoire très touchante et un film
dense qui nous raconte ce qu'est la vie
d'aujourd'hui avec du cinéma
d'aujourd'hui voilà un film à découvrir
si vous ne l'avez pas encore vu au
cinéma les yeux d'elsa encore cette
semaine de juillet
qu'ils fassent la première fois
m'avancer mais vous avez été filmée j'en
ai dit confirmé thierry vous confirmez
et puis l'autre coup de coeur est un
coup de coeur pour jeune public même si
même si on peut penser aussi que les
adultes y trouveront leur compte
c'est le dernier film des studios pixar
associé à disney vous avez vu ce que
j'ai vu envoyer un signal aux maris
voilà elle nous regarde
qu'est ce qui va la vie au pad en
personne n'écoute hf soir des poubelles
on n'a pas battu le cieux ces toilettes
quoi qu'est ce qu'on a fait on les
renvoie un signal le principe de ce film
est de nous mettre dans la tête d'une
petite fille et de ses parents en
mettant en scène non pas les humeurs des
parents extérieur mais justement nous
mettant dans leur tête
comment les choses se gère dans un
cerveau avec cinq petits personnages
l'un représentant la coquetterie l'autre
la joie l'autre la colère l'autre la
peur et un cinquième représentant la
timidité riley je n'aime pas du tout ce
genre d'attitude
c'est quoi ton problème
la smac rôti les tout-petits y
trouveront leur compte en voyant des
petits personnages s'énerver ou avoir
peur ou être fou de joie ou fou de
colère
et puis les adultes y trouveront aussi
leur compte parce qu'ils y verront une
belle fable sur la maturité sur le fait
de grandir de passer de l'âge d'enfants
à l'âge d'adolescents et puis trouveront
aussi une
une belle fable sur
le fait d'être parent ça suffit monde
dans ta chambre c'est aux commandes
c'est ici quand on marque est passée à
deux doigts de la catastrophe
c'est une catastrophe voilà bon film à
tous et bonnes vacances du sport pour
terminer cette édition l'été est
l'occasion de s'essayer à de nouvelles
disciplines pourquoi ne pas tenter le
baseball pour vous donner une idée mais
quel ennemi d'euros notre journaliste
sportif a testé pour vous cette
discipline l'équipe des cougars de
montigny le bretonneux qui évolue en
division 2 accepter de lui livrer
quelques conseils
aujourd'hui nous avons testé le baseball
la discipline qu'on près de 200 clubs et
diminue 106 en france mais avant sa
direction le vestiaire avant une session
d'entraînement avec les cougars de
montigny
bonjour coach alors oui ça va bien alors
c'est mon premier entraînement de dvd
aujourd'hui alors concrètement comment
ça se passait alors très fort on va
travailler deux choses différentes fois
d'abord travaillé la défense pourrait
être la question de l'entrée est de
rattraper la balle et après la frappe ça
marche
ok allez c'est parti donc avec la main
gauche pour un droitier leur en dessous
et la main droite et au dessus et après
tu sais revoilà dans les phalanges ok ok
donc pas les mains écartées les mains
collées hockey et le but c'est d'être
pas la relaxe
ok donc on garde les mains en haut donc
là vous allez vers l'arrière voilà donc
vraiment la coupe est allé
ça
ainsi pour
c'est vraiment compliqué je m'attendais
quand même à plus de un peu plus simple
pour un sens galère un peu des positions
du course
les jours se place ou sur terre dans un
match on a neuf joueurs sur terre il ya
le lanceur qui est là le receveur qui va
frapper des balles 10 danseurs le
troisième base le short seconde base
premières bases et après trois joueurs
enchante d'accord donc les oranje sont
vous rattraper plus tôt les balle de
volée qui sont en l'air et ceux qui sont
ici en une file vont aggraver plutôt les
balles frappées au sol courte on a neuf
joueurs de position sur le terrain et il
faut quelle qualité en général pour
autant tous les postes c'est pour
apporter un soutien spécifique est assez
spécifique à chaque position
généralement aux premières balles contre
quelqu'un de grand avec un grand a
plutôt sûr pour ramasser les balles en
deuxième base et short up
généralement ça va être le meilleur
joueur parce qu'il est rapide avec des
mains aussi rapide et un bon bras en
troisième base on aura aussi un joueur
sera solide défensivement avec un gros
bras parce que c'est la distance la plus
longue à couvrir pour faire le mort en
première
le catcheur savez celui qui va analyser
un petit peu toutes les situations fonds
qui possède aussi un bon bras et qu'ils
aient de bonnes jambes et le lanceur ça
va être celui qui va lancer la balle
fort précis qui va tenter d'éliminer les
frappeurs adverses
voilà donc ça c'est le matériel du
receveur
donc c'est lui qui va frapper les balles
du lanceur comme les bals arrive assez
vite il faut des protections notamment
quand les balles vont au sol ou qu'elles
sont frappés par le frappeur sur lui
donc il ya le plastron le 4 est
légendaire je te laisse tablier regretté
m
jean françois roubaud peuple et je suis
pas à réparer
pas mal pas mal lu son objectif ça va
être de te lancer trois strike et
illuminées sachant que toi pour être
pourra se voir que tu feras pour arriver
souvent une soin de soi en trois et plus
tu frappera fort plus tu pour accueillir
les bases toqué et dès que tu fais le
tour des bases c'est un point donc aller
les gros ça rigole puis en la maintenant
oui oui bon secours ouais
je les touche et après je sais pas ce
sens au centre tentative je sais pas
mais entre eux c'est jouissif encore
vous avez combien de conscience du coût
à 30% pour les bons frappeurs oui mais
c'est bien tu as fait a fait de même
provoqué par bercy j'espère que vous me
donnez envie de faire du baseball si
vous avez encore quelques gouttes et
bien venez voir tout simplement les
cougars de montigny jouer je pense
qu'ils sont vraiment meilleur que moi
michael et demi d'euros justement nous a
rejoint éclaté au l'amicale cette
expérience plus de 100 tentative ce
qu'est ce qui était plus compliqué
finalement même plus compliqué c'est
tout simplement de bien analyser la
distance en fait entre la balle et
labatt c'était vraiment pas évident du
tout parce que là je pense que si on
mettait toutes mes tentatives on aurait
passé à peu près deux heures son
reportage
donc c'était vraiment pas facile on a
l'expérience d'une bonne expérience mais
je recommande à tout le monde
alors pour ce dernier 7,8 ce week-end de
la saison vous allez vous proposer
quelques activités portant sportive pour
cet été ces salles yolaine il y aura du
cyclisme 7 était évidemment après
paris-nice et les championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste les yvelines vont
accueillir la compétition paris brest
paris une course mythique créée en 1891
et qui est organisé tous les quatre ans
la compétition aura comme point de
départ et comme point d'arrivée le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
au total plus de 5000 personnes est
devenue de 50 pays sont attendus pour
participer à cette randonnée
cyclotouriste à noter donc dans vos
agendas le départ est programmé le 16
août à partir de 16 heures et la
cérémonie de clôture le jeudi 20 août à
17 heures une autre idée de loisirs pour
ses vacances pour les plus téméraires
d'entre vous et surtout pour ceux qui
n'ont pas le vertige verticale arte
propose de prendre vous propose de
prendre de la hauteur à montigny le
bretonneux et d'escalader les parois de
son complexe des nouveaux blocs viennent
dette de lier d'être inauguré la salle
est ouverte tous les jours du lundi au
vendredi de 11 heures à 23 heures et le
week-end de 9h à 12h à 21h pardon pour
une séance d'une heure il faudra
débourser entre 8 euros pour les enfants
et 13 euros pour les adultes
goncourt proposera également de
nombreuses activités pour les vacances
estivales csii au yen à guyancourt la
ville propose en libre accès huit
terrains multisports pour vous défouler
cet été un terrain de football
synthétique est notamment mis à
autre disposition derrière le gymnase
maurice baquet et en terrains de beach
volley sera également installé à quoi
derrière le gymnase des droits de
l'homme enfants pour les amoureux de
sports extrêmes extrêmes les rend peu
disquette parle de villeroy sont
ouvertes tous les jours
enfin l'été enceinte vient de s'ouvrir à
montigny le bretonneux dans le gymnase
alain colas pardon jusqu'au 23 août des
dizaines d'animations sont organisées
dans la structure par des bénévoles et
tout cela des pieds dans s'améliora cet
été des cours de zumba des matchs de
beach volley des randonnées encore du
tai chi
au total une vingtaine d'activités sont
organisées au gymnase alain colas à
partir de 10h30
le programme complet est à retrouver sur
le site internet de montille retenue
voilà lionel vous connaissez de toutes
les activités qui sont proposées cet été
est ce que vous êtes plutôt beach volley
ou plutôt escalade j'ai tenté des deux
je pense les deux vont elles pas plutôt
que les volets n'ont pas forcément dans
les petits mots yolaine c'était votre
dernière émission donc sur tv fil 78
je voulais de la part de la rédaction
vous souhaiter bon courage pour la suite
de votre carrière
merci beaucoup michael en effet c'est la
force de cette édition est la saison se
termine également j'en profite pour
remercier toute la rédaction qui a
travaillé sur cette émission
les monteurs et les réalisateurs
également romain les spins exergue
roland russe finit xavier jaglin
sandrine font-elles sans oublier aurélia
débit hsi et notre super stagiaires anna
jimenez et son accent inoubliable le
site week end revient à l'année
prochaine rendez vous le vendredi 11
septembre
mais c'est là je vous souhaite un
excellent été à tous